autonomous drones
operated on a boat that sails itself
this ai could soon carry out some of the
most
dangerous jobs a team from bristol
university
is developing drones which will land on
wind turbines out at sea
to carry out vital repairs the number of
turbines
we have is is almost growing
exponentially there's a large number out
there
they're offshore they're in an
environment which is really challenging
and we have to be able to repair them
over the long term to keep them
generating power for us the uk's plan to
become a leader in wind energy
means there's now a real need for this
technology
a fact that is now fast tracking this
development
the team says having unmanned boats and
autonomous drones land on wind turbines
offshore to repair them
is as little as five years away but it
is not
the only use for this technology
team from southampton university is also
working on using a fleet of these
autonomous boats
to head out to sea and collect plastic
waste from the oceans
we do know there's bits of the ocean
where the water all the plastic comes
together
it's still spread over quite a large
area and so what we have the opportunity
with
with sort of robot vehicles is to
actually sort of spread them over a long
large area and use relatively few people
indeed know people
who actually get them to operate
together and
collectively you know face the challenge
of how we can remove
these unwanted materials from the ocean
the multinational engineering firm
talis is leading this ai technology it
says this is not about
taking away work from humans it's really
really important that
um in in this type of business um we're
not
we're not sort of taking over people's
jobs but what we're doing is we're
augmenting that into people's roles and
making things more efficient
you know we're going green we're using
less carbon
all of those sorts of things can be done
through the use of autonomy
from clearing ocean plastics to
repairing wind turbines the concept
of autonomous technology is fast
becoming a reality
dan whitehead sky news in plymouth